foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
Bible related question give us a call
now at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor
Hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
back in 1922 after a minor slip in a
fall at work an Iowa man started
hiccuping and he didn't stop for 68
years
over the weeks months and years Charles
Osborne tried everything to get rid of
his pesky condition
he traveled cross country to visit
doctors and even resorted to hormone
therapy but it seemed that nothing could
cure his chronic hiccups not wanting
experimental surgery Osborne eventually
learned to hiccup quietly and live with
his annoying condition he did marry and
had a job and had a family
but one day in 1990 after 68 years of
non-stop hiccups when Osborne was 96
years old his hiccups mysteriously
stopped
his last months of Life were thankfully
hiccup free
Osborne's condition also earned him a
place in the Guinness Book of World
Records in an interview with Johnny
Carson on The Tonight Show it's
estimated that between the ages of 29
and 96 Osborne hiccupt 430 million times
and doctors never did figure out
precisely what caused his lifelong
affliction
you know Pastor Ross that's what you
would call a a mystery a conundrum an
enigma where did his hiccups come from
and where did they go they just stopped
after 68 years
and uh the Bible talks about oh I think
22 times it uses the word mystery
there are some Mysteries you know you
get the mystery of godliness and then
the Bible tells us in what second
Thessalonians chapter 2 about the
mystery of iniquity people want to know
where did Sin come from that's right one
of the questions that we often have is
if God is a god of love and he's
all-powerful why do we live in a world
where there is sun and suffering and
death well the Bible gives us the answer
however there is that element of mystery
the Bible speaks about the mystery of
iniquity that self-centeredness that
arose in the heart of a beautiful angel
Lucifer in heaven and you know we do
have a study guide that talks about this
it's an important subject people often
wonder if God is good why is there bad
in the world did God create a devil
that's one of the questions people have
well we have a study guide part of the
amazing facts Study Guide Series and it
talks about the origin of evil and we'll
send this lesson for free it's called
did God create a devil you might be
surprised when you read and study this
we'll send it to anyone here in the
United States in Canada all you need to
do is call the number
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
study guide It's called did God create a
devil and if you have a cell phone you
can also just dial pound 250 say Bible
answers live and ask for the study guide
did God create a devil we'll be happy to
send you a digital copy or through the
mail and if you're outside of North
America you can just go to the Amazing
Facts website just
amazingfacts.org and Pastor I it's
probably a good time for us to greet our
friends who are watching and listening
across the country and in other places
through the internet around the world I
know our program is rebroadcast on a
number of different television networks
as well so we'd like to greet our
friends listening and if you'd like to
see what's happening here this is live
this evening
you can just simply go to the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page or the amazing
facts Facebook page we're also live on
YouTube and you can call in with your
Bible question the number year to the
studio is
800-463-7297 that's
800-463-7297 and you'll be able to get
your Bible question on the air this
evening
well before we go to the phone lines
let's start with the word of prayer dear
father we thank you that we have this
time where we can just uh open up your
word and study Lord we know the Bible is
your book so we do pray for the holy
spirit to guide us be with our friends
who are listening wherever they might be
and lead us into a clearer understanding
of the teachings of the Bible in Jesus
name amen amen well Pastor Doug our
first caller this evening we're going to
get right to it we've got Gary listening
in Illinois uh Gary welcome to Bible
answers live
well my question is there are four
Angels standing at the Four Corners of
the Earth holding back the winds that
would harm the Earth uh and until the
Servants of God are sealed in their
forehead so what is to be sealed mean
and how does that play up against the
thought that Jesus did it all if I have
to do one thing to secure my salvation
I'm saying that Jesus says crucifixion
wasn't good enough okay so that's my
question okay well let's actually deal
with the last part of your question
first the idea that because we need to
do something means that Jesus sacrifice
wasn't adequate uh let me just see if I
can explain it this way if somebody
writes a check to pay a hundred percent
of your million dollar debt
and yet the bank still repossesses your
home and puts you in jail and you say
but I thought he paid everything they
said well you never took the check to
the bank
so there is something that everybody
needs to do we need to reach out and
take the gift that he's offered so there
is something that needs to be done it
doesn't mean that Jesus sacrifices
inadequate we must respond to that
sacrifice so when it says that we must
receive the Seal of God we must be born
again Jesus said unless you are born of
the water in the spirit you cannot enter
the Kingdom of Heaven you look in
Ephesians chapter 1 verse 13 it says in
him you also trusted after you heard the
word of Truth The Gospel of your
salvation in whom you also have believed
you were sealed with the Holy Spirit of
promise now there's word seal read again
in Ephesians 4 verse 30. do not grieve
the holy spirit of God by whom you are
sealed for the day of redemption now we
just read there in Revelation chapter
seven at least that's what you were
quoting Gary about people must receive
the Seal of God if they're going to
survive these plagues in this wind of
strife but there's something deeper than
just the Holy Spirit what I mean by that
is why does it say in the forehead
if you look in the Old Testament it says
that God's people this is Deuteronomy
chapter
4 verse 6. sorry no chapter 5 is where
you have the Ten Commandments repeated
chapter six is where Moses said these
words that I command you today shall be
in your heart they shall be in your hand
they shall be between your eyes so one
way that we know that we have the Holy
Spirit is by the fruits of the spirit
there's obedience in the life you read
in Isaiah chapter 8 it says bind up the
testimony seal the law among my
disciples so in the law of God is a seal
of God and it shows that we've got the
fruits of the spirit we have a whole
lesson that talks about the Seal of God
we could send to Gary or anyone that
wants to know what that is that's right
it's part of our amazing facts Study
Guide Series and you can just call and
ask for this study God the Seal of God
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
calls and asks number again he's
800-835-6747 is interesting in the Book
of Revelation not only do you have the
righteous sealed not only do they have
something symbolically in their forehead
but you also have those were lost the
wicked they also marked they get the
mark of the beast at the end of time
everyone is divided up into two groups
those with the Seal of God obedience to
God's Commandments or the mark of the
beast obedience to the Beast commandment
we want to be amongst those who have the
Seal of God in the last days thank you
for your call Gary next caller that we
have is Judith listening in Nevada
Judith welcome to the program
hello can you hear me
we do hello good evening okay great
wonderful and thanks for taking my call
again my question is related to Matthew
chapter 5 verse 48.
that were perfectly Eyes Of God my
question is uh we are the still in the
midst of the great controversy between
Christ and Satan and one saved will not
always be saved is a daily sagification
process uh and a personal relationship
with Jesus so what would you recommend
the biblical uh I would say to stop the
good to give us a warning sign a degree
good luck signs that we are not
maintaining perfection in the eyes of
God what would be your uh input as to
biblical promises that will maintain our
spiritual purification daily thank you
okay your answer yes well when Jesus
says here in Matthew Chapter 5 48
therefore be perfect just as your father
in Heaven is perfect
he talks about in the previous verses so
always read something in his context in
the previous verses he talks about
loving your brother when Jesus quotes
that same verse in the Gospel of Luke he
says be therefore merciful even as your
father in Heaven is merciful and so God
wants us to have a perfect love and a
perfect Mercy and um
so
we are called to Holiness don't
misunderstand the Bible says blessed are
the pure in heart they'll see God but as
soon as we accept Christ
he then gives us a new heart and this is
the New Covenant and we begin to think
differently instead of being and it may
not all happen in one day it's called
sanctification but instead of being
motivated by selfishness and sin now we
start being motivated by love and a
desire to please God and so there's a
change that happens in the heart Jesus
said if you love me keep my Commandments
and so as we get to know him better we
fall in love with God as we love him
better we obey him better and Jesus said
that he that has begun a good work in us
will perform it he is the author and the
finisher of our faith so if we keep
dying to self we take up our cross daily
and follow him we die to self we follow
Jesus we're being transformed into his
image that's right you know we do have a
study guide that talks about actually
one of our books talks about it's called
three steps to Heaven talks about these
different aspects of trusting in God and
experiencing that Deliverance that
cleansing that only comes from the
spirit we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
it's called three steps to Heaven we'll
be happy to send that for free 21 in the
U.S and in Canada uh if you'd like you
could dial pound 250 on your phone and
say Bible answers live and then ask for
the book three steps to heaven and you
can also receive it that way thank you
for your call Judith if you have a Bible
question just another reminder friends
our phone lines are open it's
800-463-7297 800 God says that's
804-63-7297 next color that we have is
Jimmy listening in Texas uh Jimmy
welcome to the program
yes sir thank you hello I mean Hello
pastors
thank you my question is
my question is um
I've been I think this is the truth I'm
not really sure
Christ comes back after the seven last
plagues but I'm um
um it's also written that he comes as a
thief in the night is that does that
occur after the seven last plagues or
during it well let's read it here if you
look in uh Revelation chapter 16 and you
go to verse 17. it says then the seventh
angel poured out his bowl these are the
bowls filled with the plague so the
seventh angel is the seventh plague the
seventh angel poured out his bowl into
the air and a loud voice came out of the
Temple of Heaven from the throne saying
it is done
and there were noises and thunderings
and Lightnings and there was a great
earthquake such a mighty and a great
earthquake as has not occurred since men
were on the Earth
now that great city was divided in three
parts and the cities of the Nations fell
in great Babylon was remembered before
God to give her the cup of the wine of
the fierceness of his wrath then every
island fled away and the mountains were
not found and a great hail from Heaven
fell upon men each Hailstone about the
weight of a talent and Men blasphemed
God because of the plague of hail since
that plague was exceedingly great so
it's understood this great earthquake in
the hail are mentioned other places with
the second coming of Christ that the
seventh plague is really the end for the
world it's every island fled away the
cities are destroyed you can read in
Revel I'm sorry in Jeremiah chapter 4 it
talks about the cities are broken down
by the presence of the Lord and through
his Fierce anger so when you read that
he's coming like a thief it just means
that it's going to surprise people when
these plagues Begin to Fall people are
going to just be blindsided by it all so
yeah I think it's since no one knows the
day or the hour it's going to surprise
people let me just read that verse pass
it out because it's it's interesting
second Peter chapter 3 and verse 10 it
says but the doubt of the Lord will come
as a thief in the night and there you
have it but it says in which the heavens
will pass away with a great noise and
the elements will melt with fervent Heat
and the earth and the works thereof will
be burnt up so there you have Jesus
coming as a thief of the night but when
he comes talks about the heavens passing
away and the Earth melting with fervent
heat so there's nothing secret about the
coming of Jesus so when Christ comes as
a thief it's it's not the manner of
Christ coming but it's the
unexpectedness he comes and catches the
majority of the World by surprise right
and this is right at the conclusion of
the seven last plagues you know we do
have a study guide talking about the
second coming and it's called anything
but secret it's actually one of our
books and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks again that
number is 800-835-600 747 and you can
ask for the book it's called anything
but secret we'll be happy to send it to
anyone dial pound 250 on your phone and
just say Bible answers live and you can
receive the book that way as well the
next quality that we have is Brittany
listening uh in Jamaica Brittany welcome
to the program
hi pastor
hello
a cold can you know if God is calling
you to evangelism
well if you read in Matthew chapter 28
Jesus said to his disciples all power is
given unto me go therefore and teach All
Nations baptizing them in the name of
the father Son and Holy Spirit the
teaching he's telling us to go and teach
and make disciples and so that
invitation to make disciples using our
various spiritual gifts was not just for
the apostles
but I think every believer to some ex to
some extent is supposed to be sharing
their faith now whether you're called
the full-time evangelism or not I don't
know
um I think that a lot of people have the
gifts are certain gifts that can be used
in evangelism and they maybe just need
some training or discipling amazing
facts actually has a program called AFCO
and it's the amazing fact Center of
evangelism where we teach men and women
how to do what are some of the different
aspects of evangelism there are
different parts of evangelism you've got
what we think of the Evangelist standing
in front of a group of people and
they're preaching the Bible but there's
also parts of evangelism they don't
always think of one is is Bible work
where somebody's actually doing Bible
studies one-on-one or maybe in
somebody's home in a group that's an
important part part of evangelism
there's something else we call
literature evangelism where people are
actually going out and they're using
material and they're sharing it with
other people that way the people can
read and come to an understanding of
true truth so there are different ways
in which we can let our light shine and
we want to say Lord what are the gifts
what are the talents that you've given
me how can I use this for the
furtherance of your kingdom now it might
evolve preaching others have the gift of
music and they can use their music to
glorify God and bring people a knowledge
of the truth so each person has got
different gifts and we want to use those
gifts the best way we can yeah if people
want to know more about the amazing
facts uh evangelism training and we've
got what thousands of graduates around
the world now you can simply go to
afcoafcoe
afco.org and I think they can even do a
lot of it online that's right we have
several of the classes available online
and again just go to the Amazing Facts
website or AFCO you can if you can't
remember AFCO just go to amazing facts
and you can click on the training link
and you can get all the information
about our evangelism training program
that we have now Brittany real quick let
me just give you more of a direct answer
to your question you're saying how do I
know if he's calling me you you tell the
Lord say Lord I am willing to go and
watch and see if he opens the doors if
you're willing to go and do something
more full-time say Lord if this is your
will
open the doors in the meantime do what
lies closest to hand with all you know
all your might be faithful and whatever
your current work is say Lord open the
doors he's done it for me several times
and that's one way I knew okay next
caller that we have is Jesus listening
in Florida Jesus welcome to the program
hello how are you guys doing today great
thank you for calling
yeah yes okay so
um in Acts chapter 2 verse 13. it talks
about new wine specifically in the
context of people mocking
um those who are in the upper room that
had received the Holy Spirit uh and I'm
I'm assuming that it's insinuating that
they're drunk
um now I've always heard the context
that new wine symbolizes unfermented
wine right like the first um
uh the first miracle of Jesus as well
when he talks about it later so I'm
wondering does that comp does that
conflict with that idea and how are we
supposed to understand that
yeah well when let me just for our
friends that are listening when the Holy
Spirit was poured out on the apostles
there in Acts chapter 2 and they began
to preach with power and they were
speaking in other languages to the
people present
so you know I think it mentioned 16
different language groups there by the
time you get to
um verse 12.
and so it sounded like babbling to some
that were listening and so some of the
Jews were mocking and they said oh
they're full of new wine and the word
new wine their new wine is clearly not
fermented
but people would stumble around
sometimes and they say Oh I thought it
was new wine
and they they'd be drinking they'd be
drinking old wine and then they'd say oh
no but I thought it was new wine so that
was sort of like a cop-out and they're
mocking the disciples and oh they're
full of new wine
um but no new wine doesn't get you drunk
they were just using this as sarcasm I
guess you would say yeah there's also
something else interesting in the Greek
there if you look up the word new wine
it can also be translated as sweet wine
now the Passover all Pentecost rather
occurred somewhere around June but you'd
have the Harvest of the grapes not until
August so what they would do is they
would somehow try and concentrate this
this juice
and then that add water and they could
use it as as grape juice it would be
sweet so you could use the word sweet
wine instead of new wine because new
wine is is the juice that comes fresh
from the grapes and you didn't have that
all year round that was something that
was at the Harvest so um yeah if you're
drinking juice out of grape unless
they're very old grapes they're not
fermented that's right yeah that's right
you know we do have a book and you may
have some questions about this
um Jesus and it's called alcohol in the
Christian we can send you or anyone who
wants to know what does the Bible say
about alcohol we can send you a free
copy the number to call is
800-835-6747 and you can ask the book
it's called alcohol and the Christian
you can also dial pound 250 on your
phone and say Bible answers live or
amazing facts and ask for that book the
Christian and alcohol
next holder that we have is Richard
listening Canada Richard welcome to
Bible answers live
hi
uh I have a quest a question and it uh
uh revolves around uh something Jesus
said in Matthew 23 verses 8 through 10.
um
is it appropriate for Christians to
uh call each other
uh
or except to be called by each other by
honorific titles like Pastor Bishop
um or is that or should we
refer to each other by our by our names
whatever
position we may hold
yeah well it's it's not wrong to address
a person by a an appropriate title if
you're going to see your doctor
uh you know his name might be Robert you
don't necessarily need to say hey Bob
you know there I think people are due
certain respect based on offices I know
if you're in the military and you've got
a sergeant you call him buddy well you
might end up getting thrown in the brig
so it's appropriate to call people by uh
certain respectful titles but when it
comes to the church Jesus said call no
man father for you of one father so
there's at least one term there and then
you know Pastor Ross and I people say
should we call you Reverend should we
call you father and we say no the Bible
says holy and Reverend are meaning
revered is his name and so we don't use
the word reverend but the the word
minister or title is also a descriptive
word and there's nothing wrong with
using the descriptive word if you say a
person is wearing a gray suit it doesn't
mean that you're
giving them any kind of undue honor it's
just a descriptive term so to call a
person by their descriptive profession
and saying Pastor Doug or Pastor Jean
nothing wrong with that we just don't
want to take the reverence belongs to
God and we have really one father we
should not be giving a man that title
God is our father
does that make sense
Richard
it it does but he also talks about uh uh
Rabbi and master
yeah uh those were also honorific titles
that were used
yeah well telling his disciples yeah and
I Think Jesus is talking more
specifically about the the teachers and
the scribes and they loved the titles
they loved the the greetings they loved
the best seats they wanted the honor of
men and if a person wants to be a pastor
or a minister so that they can get a
title well that's certainly the wrong
reason but I think it's important to use
some terms of respect you know with our
kids when we when your children are
young and they're talking to other
adults it's good for them to call Mr
Brown or Mr Smith we don't have our kids
talk to another adult when they're young
and say hey Stanley it just doesn't
sound right used to be you know you'd
address them with more respect
and so there's nothing wrong with terms
of respect but we shouldn't be craving
titles for Prestige you know just to add
a little bit to that Pastor you know in
our church it's interesting we have a
weekly bulletin we put together the
different
um positions connected with our our
service and in our bulletin we don't put
titles we don't say Dr so and so pass or
so and so now on the back of the
bulletin it mentions who the pastors are
in the church but when it comes to the
church and it comes to worshiping it is
valuable for someone that might be
visiting to know who the leader of the
church is who's the pastor of the church
there's nothing wrong with that but as
we interact with each other you know we
try to minimize uh the titles that would
sort of in God's eyes we're all Brothers
and Sisters in Christ yeah and sometimes
the term brother so and so you'll hear
in the church or sister soul and so more
so than you'll hear a title like doctor
or some other person
good question all right thank you for
your call next wallet that we have is uh
now listening in California
Nell welcome
hi thank you so much Pastor thank you my
question is in regard to investing
um I'm a little bit new at it but I know
that some of the
um some things like that um if you
invest in a like I'm using the wrong
term but in a composite manner some of
those might contain uh things that we
may not necessarily believe in like you
might invest in a alcohol company or
something like that and so if you're
doing that is is it a problem or or do
we have to like speak different you know
separately speak things to invest right
that's a great question so if you're a
Christian and you're going to invest and
it is appropriate to invest Jesus talked
about the Unfaithful Steward that just
buried the money and Jesus said you
could have at least put it in the bank
now when you put your money in a bank
the banks invest your money they might
invest it in some companies that you
know you might not support it might be
an entertainment or an alcohol or
Tobacco Company usually that's not all
of it but that might be in the bouquet
you can't always control what your
bank's going to do but on a personal
level
stock advisors and financial advisors do
tell Christians and just anybody with
some morals they might say I want to
invest in a mutual fund that doesn't
have the sin company sometimes they'll
use a term like that it's not investing
in you know the alcohol or the tobacco
or some of these other dubious companies
people can choose to invest in a sector
of just technology or something or
medicine or whatever so I think as
Christians you need to be careful not to
try to exploit companies or make money
off companies that have are morally
questionable that's a good thing for you
to ask you may not always be able to
control what your bank does with the
money and it's a different issue but
just like when you go to the supermarket
you buy your oranges they may also sell
alcohol but you don't buy the alcohol
hey we'll be back with more questions
friends don't go anywhere
foreign
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
hi friends Pastor Doug Batchelor this
morning my wife Karen sent me on a
mission she said when you're taping your
announcements this morning tell people
about my favorite amazing facts app it's
called The Amazing Facts radio app you
simply type that in amazing facts radio
you can download the app and you can
listen to good Christian music Bible
reading sermons all day long keep your
faith focused in heaven through the day
check it out if you haven't done it yet
the amazing facts radio app you'll be
blessed
every year forty thousand souls in North
America end their own lives
suicide is a terrible tragedy and while
it's difficult to talk about we need to
face it together as Christians
that's why in my new book choosing life
I share the biblical perspective about
suicide answering some difficult
questions about faith and salvation
along the way and offering practical
tips that should help and encourage
others Jesus wants us to choose an
abundant life in him
have you ever skipped a meal not a bad
idea if you need to watch your waistline
but there's a Heavenly food you should
never skip God's word yet how can you
dive in Daily when you're so busy
amazing facts has you covered and it's
as easy as signing up for our daily
devotional and verse of the day both
sent directly to your inbox ready to
bless Inspire and inform you to start
receiving the amazing facts Daily
Devotional and verse of the day visit
amazingfacts.org and click on Bible
study in the main menu you'll be glad
you did
hi friends Pastor Doug Batchelor it's
time to make your plans and mark your
calendars to attend our third annual
amazing facts youth conference the dates
are June 7th through the 10th 2023. this
year's Mission and title is called
identity change by beholding come and
learn how to turn your focus from the
world to the word and make some great
friends along the way for more
information about the speakers and how
you can register go to afyouth.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian Life call us now
at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends for those
who tuned in somewhere along the way
this is a live International interactive
Bible study and we encourage you to
participate we've got some lines open
Pastor Ross if people want to call in
all they've got to do is call that
toll-free number
800-463-7297 and we're streaming on
Facebook right now they can watch the
program it's the Doug Batchelor Facebook
page or the amazing facts Facebook page
it's on YouTube Amazing Facts YouTube
We're airing I think live on AF TV and
rebroadcast and other stations but
you've got a Bible question Now's the
Time pick up the phone give us a call
we've got some room left for the second
half of the program we'd love to hear
from you my name is Doug Batchelor my
name is Jean Ross and also friends if
you can't call in maybe you're listening
to a rebroadcast of this program and
you'd like to ask a question you cannot
do so by sending an email and I'll give
you the address that's balquestions at
amazing fact dot org just Bal questions
at amazingfacts.org but right now we are
live so if you'd like to call in and ask
your question
800-463-7297 we're going to go to Bob
listening in Washington Bob welcome to
the program
hey gentlemen thank you Brothers yeah uh
dragons young my question is
um
when the latter rain comes in the 144
000 are spreading the three angles
messages
the other Christians on the planet that
are not part of
or counted part of the 140 000 will they
be doing the same thing
yeah well I think as we near the end of
time every believer is engaged in
sharing the the good news
I think the key to understanding who the
hundred and forty four thousand are can
be found in Acts chapter 2. in Acts
chapter 2 we know that they were the
first thing that happens actually in
Acts chapter 1
is they do a head count and they say you
know we are short one apostle there were
12 Jesus wanted 12 even though there
were not 12 tribes of Israel left
because they had been scattered he said
we need 12 Apostles
and Judas had killed himself
so Peter said let's pick a replacement
and I trust he was led by the spirit
they cast lots they picked a replacement
as soon as they got back to the number
12 the Holy Spirit was poured out and
there's a great Revival now the Holy
Spirit did not just fall on the 12
apostles in the upper room it says there
were 120 in the upper room so it's 10
times more than just the 12.
the ones who receive the special filling
in the last days are not just the 144
000. the 144 000 are very much like last
day Apostles they have a special work to
do a special calling and uh but they're
not the only ones saved there's a great
multitude that was saved from the
preaching of the Apostles and the
disciples in the upper room and they
were baptized at Pentecost in the last
days the holy spirit is going to fall on
thousands Way Beyond just the 144 000
and I think there'll be a Revival that
will sweep the world as it did in the
first Centuries with Christianity
and we have a book talks about the
subject that's right it's called hula
the 144 000 and we'll be happy to send
this to you a bob or anyone wanting to
learn more about that uh just before we
give the number again pass it like just
to add to that a little bit you know he
asked about the latter rain there might
be some folks who are wondering well
what is it talking about the latter rain
yeah well in Bible times uh they had
what they called the former rain and the
latter rain connected with the Harvest
they were an Agricultural Society
and they always prayed especially that
there'd be this good rain that would
Sprout the seed and then just before the
Harvest there would be another rain that
would help it to plump up uh before the
Harvest and in the same way Jesus
scattered the seed of the Gospel with
his three and a half years of ministry
then the Holy Spirit was poured out at
Pentecost and you had like the former
Reign before Christ comes to harvest and
he pictures himself coming with a sickle
in his hand in Revelation to harvest
it's a symbol
they'll be the latter reign of the Holy
Spirit to prepare the crop of souls so
it uses that farming terminology in
connection with the second coming okay
the book that we mentioned it's called
who will sing the song understanding the
144 000 and that is for free we'll send
it to anyone in the U.S or in Canada the
number to call for that is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
book who will sing the song
understanding the hundred and forty four
thousand or you can just dial pound 250
on your phone and say Bible answers live
and then ask for the book about the 144
000. next color that we have is Kim and
he's listening from Iowa Kim Welcome to
the program
thank you okay sorry Kim there's a
couple of different gyms out there okay
no worries I have a question I have this
discussion with a lady that I work with
it's um first Timothy Chapter 4 verses
four and five and about unclean and
clean Meats to be eaten not to be eaten
but she claims that the scripture
negates everything
all right well let's read this for our
friends that are listening if you look
in first Timothy chapter four and I'll
read four and five
it says for every creature of God is
good and nothing to be is to be refused
if it's received with Thanksgiving for
it is Sanctified by the word of God In
Prayer now
um you need to go back to verse 3 really
where he says that there'll be this you
know Fallen power in the last days that
will command people not to marry all
right that's a clue right there there's
going to be a religious movement that
will tell its priests they can't marry
uh 10 seconds you got to figure out the
answer to that and then it says they'll
command people to abstain from foods
that the Bible says can be eaten because
they're Sanctified by the word of God
well they say like you can or can't eat
fish on a certain day clean or unclean
and so this is talking about a
particular movement in the last days now
when Paul says for every creature of God
is good and nothing to be refused there
was a big debate in the church in Paul's
day where the Christians were being told
by the Jewish Believers these are
believers in Christ but they're coming
from a Jewish background
that they couldn't eat any meat that was
sold in the Roman Greek marketplaces
because it had been offered to Idols
before it was sacrificed
and they said you will be participating
in idolatry even if you buy that chicken
that's hanging there in the meat market
because before they slaughtered the
chicken they did it in front of a little
Idol to some God
well Paul said the idol is nothing if
you don't if that doesn't bother your
conscience don't do it if it does bother
your conscience we'll just eat
vegetables and don't eat the meat if it
bothers your brother don't do it there's
a big debate in the New Testament about
can you eat things that were offered to
idols
and Paul said well if you're not
offering it to an idol and you just bind
it in the market then don't ask any
questions for conscience sake it's
something like today my wife and I love
going to a Thai restaurant one of the
Thai restaurants we go to it's got like
a statue of Buddha in there when you
walk in well that doesn't bother me I'm
not going to worship Buddha and I don't
feel like God thinks I'm worshiping
Buddha by eating there
someone if I went with a brother and
sister and they said oh Doug we can't
eat here there's a statue of Buddha at
the entrance I said all right well let's
go somewhere else
so there was this kind of debate it had
nothing to do with the clean Meats so
much as things sacrificed the idols
Paul is saying every creature of God is
good
and nothing to be refused if it's
received with Thanksgiving he's talking
about for it is Sanctified by the word
of God there are some animals that the
word of God says you can't eat they're
called clean animals
and there are some you cannot eat
they're called unclean it's called an
abomination
God is not saying that you just pray
over anything and it becomes clean it's
really absurd to think that you tell
your children I don't care what you eat
for breakfast just make sure you pray
over it no you know that there's
nutritional value and you're going to
reap what you sow so
uh I we have a study guide that we can
share and she can give this to her
friend study guide is called God's free
health plan and we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks the
numbers
800-835-6747 ask for the study guide
God's free health plan or dial pound 250
on your smartphone and say Bible answers
live and ask for that study guide God's
free health plan next holiday we have
thank you uh Kim next holiday we have is
Carlos listening in Florida Carlos
welcome to the program
how you doing pastors doing great
thanks for calling
so Mike my question is um I'm watching
uh
a Joe Cruz on a sermon here on Sabbath
and uh so this is in regards to Sabbath
if it should be kept if us Christians
today should keep Sabbath or not and he
came to a verse that was uh he's he's
um he's reading out a uh something that
Billy Graham wrote and and it came to
Romans 10 10 8-10 but he didn't really
read the verse he just kind of kept uh I
don't think he read the verse anyways I
was looking for what the verse in in the
Bible as he was talking but I couldn't
tell if he was really talking but didn't
seem like he was speaking scripture how
does that eight Romans 8 through 10 uh
10 Romans 10 8-10 uh relate to keeping
of the Sabbath or keeping of the laws
all right well first of all about
keeping you're talking about and I don't
mean to jump in but you're talking about
a scripture reference that is given
during a sermon that you are watching is
that correct yes sir all right it is
entirely possible I've done it before
that he misquoted the reference or
quoted the wrong reference in the wrong
place so I'll read this for our friends
I'm not sure that could be the problem
but let me read what it says here in
Romans chapter 10 I think you said verse
8 through 10 and it said
but what does it say the word is near
you and in your mouth and in your heart
that is a Word of Faith which we preach
that if you confess with your mouth the
Lord Jesus and if you believe in your
heart that God has raised him from the
dead you will be saved for where the
Hard One Believes into righteousness and
with the mouth confession is made unto
salvation now that is a powerful verse
that is often used in person accepting
Christ and receiving forgiveness and
righteousness by faith
I don't know that I would use that
connected with the Sabbath I think maybe
what um and Carlos if if we understand
what the argument is I think some people
say well this verse says you just need
to confess with your mouth and believe
in your heart and that's all you have to
do you don't have to keep the law yeah
but Billy Graham believes you should
keep the law too yeah so yeah I had a
feeling um I had a feeling he was uh on
the wrong uh made a mistake on the
scripture there but what he was saying
was something along the lines of what
should we do now that we're living
through faith does it mean that we could
just continue to that's then that would
be Romans chapter six shall we continue
and send that Grace might abound God
forbid yes that's what I was looking for
you know what it may have quoted it's
Romans chapter well there's two places
you got Romans chapter six and you've
got Romans chapter 7 talks about that
let me see Romans 6 verse 1 What then
shall we say shall we continue in sin
that Grace May abound God God for me
it's certainly not how shall we who are
dead to sin meaning lawlessness live any
longer in it
and amen that's the one I was looking
for yeah so it may mean that he may have
meant to quote that one I don't know of
course I don't know what sermon you're
listening to but do you know the service
I'm looking at no I don't know Joe Cruz
has preached thousands of sermons so
don't quiz me on that I have no idea
which one you're listening to
and yes this has helped a lot actually
all right about Romans 6 right yeah
Romans 6 verse 1 and there's another one
in Romans 6 2. um well he says you know
he that is he that is dead is uh freed
from sin
but um
let me see here
yeah do not let sin reign in your more
you read all of Romans 6. you'll be the
whole thing is over there yeah hey
thanks Carlos uh you know what I would I
would offer Carlos that book does God's
grace plot out the law it's an excellent
book because he quotes that there again
he's called does God's grace blot out
the law the number is 800 835 that is by
Joe Cruz six seven four seven written by
Joe Cruz uh we'll send that to anyone
who calls and asks you can also dial
pound 250. say Bible answers live and
ask for the book does God's grace blot
out the lull next goal that we have is
Cami listening from California can we
walk into the program
hello pastors good evening thank you for
taking my call yes so my question this
evening is dealing with the story about
Saul and the witch indoor in first
Samuel chapter 28 and when you get down
to the 15th verse it says and Samuel
said to Saul why hast thou just quieted
me to bring me up
etc etc
and so I'm wondering is why does the
word of God say that it was Samuel when
we know that it wasn't
well I think it's just saying through
the perspective of those that were
present that day this Apparition this
spirit
said who she says is you know Samuel
says why did you disturb me now later we
read that they are the spirits of devils
working miracles
and Satan then you can read in second
Corinthians chapter 11 Satan himself can
be transformed into an angel of Light so
if the devil and his angels can
transform themselves and to create
Illusions and they're the spirits of
devils working miracles and then you can
also read in Kings it talks about lying
Spirits where Michaela the prophet came
before Ahab they said they are lying
Spirits so
um I think it's pretty and you've got
that other verse where it says a medium
yeah first Chronicles chapter 10 verse
13. it says the soul died for his
unfaithfulness in which he committed
against the Lord because they did not
keep the word of the Lord and also
because he consulted a medium for
guidance yeah so you know there it is a
familiar spirit is another term that's
sometimes used
yeah so I know when you read it they're
just you know they're saying that this
thing obviously looked and sounded like
Samuel or it was impersonating Samuel so
that's the name that was given to it but
it wasn't really Samuel
and I'm looking where's it at Isaiah
chapter 8 verse yeah Isaiah 8 19.
and when they say to you seek those who
are mediums or medium supposedly
connects you with the dead world the
spirit world
seek those were mediums and wizards who
whisper and mutter should not a people
seek their God should they seek the dead
on behalf of the living
and then you read where Solomon says the
living know their die but the dead know
nothing so and then obviously does the
devil have the ability to resurrect dead
Saints no only Jesus has he's got the
keys of life and death in the
resurrection so by all other counts it's
what you would call the um the uh
preponderance of evidence this was a
satanic uh impersonator
right does that make sense
it does and I just wanted to say too
before I go that in verse 14 it says um
and Saul perceived that it that it was
Samuel and he stooped with his face to
the ground and bowed himself and so
realizing that the so-called Samuel did
not immediately correct him and say you
know don't bow to me
you should only bow to the Lord yeah as
an angel would do we know too that that
couldn't have been Samuel
yeah and you know when we go uh
they weren't supposed to consult witches
because what's happening is you're going
on Enchanted ground you're going on the
Devil's Ground and then we're wide open
to deception and that's what happened to
Saul
and because he went to that witch
uh and he believes the message of the
evil spirit he did get discouraged the
next day he had no courage to lead his
men into battle they lost miserably and
he killed himself committed suicide like
Judas
so that was a lion Spirit we have a
whole lesson that talks about the witch
of Endor that's right and uh you
thinking about the lesson in historicals
that's right now that's available online
if you go to the Amazing Facts website
and just look up the study guide It's
called The Witch of Endor and it
actually goes into more detail on the
subject next quality we have is Linda
listening in South Carolina Linda
welcome to the program
hello guys how are you doing wonderful
thank you for calling
I I have a question about the
um destruction of Jerusalem and the
temple what did it signify and what what
is the sign for us again is it the
drying up of the Euphrates rivers
all right that's how you've asked the
big question first of all what did it
signify the destruction of the temple
well God instructed the children of
Israel to build the temple originally
because it's where they learned the Plan
of Salvation
they had the Tabernacle in the
wilderness that was a mobile Temple that
they first built then David gathered
material and Solomon built a beautiful
Temple that was the biggest and the best
of the three then that was destroyed by
Nebuchadnezzar and then they came back
in the days of Ezra Nehemiah they
rebuilt the Third Temple it was later
refurbished by Herod the Great Jesus
said because they did not accept him
he said your house is left unto you
desolate there would not be left one
stone upon another Christ had destroyed
this Temple made with hands speaking of
his body and I'll make one without hands
the church so when Jesus died on the
cross the veil in the temple was torn
signifying the whole purpose for the
Earthly Temple pointing to Jesus the
Lamb of God was fulfilled
and so there was no need to sacrifice
Lambs anymore because Christ is now the
real Lamb of God that all that pointed
to but they continued with their
sacrifices even after Jesus ascended to
Heaven that Temple was destroyed in 70
A.D and it's never going to be rebuilt
again now the temple is the church
the Bible says what don't you know that
ye are the temple of God Christ built a
temple and you and I are that Temple
Peter says we are living stones in the
temple of God or that's actually in
Ephesians so um that's what's indicated
by the temple being destroyed back then
the emphasis now in the New Testament is
not on the physical Temple because that
kind of takes you to the old sacrificial
system the emphasis now is on
Christ and the church and Christ is
ministering before the real temple of
God in heaven he is our high priest and
that's in Hebrews chapter 8 and 9. I'm
not mistaken so now you asked about the
angels and the your river Euphrates
that's connected with the sixth plague
were you referring to the drying up of
the river Euphrates
yes is that a symbol for us to leave the
cities and
um
and and and and get ready for the coming
of the Lord
well the physical drying up of the river
Euphrates I think is interesting but
it's not the the final fulfillment of
the sixth plague
the the sixth plague oh well boy I'm
looking at the clock and thinking I
don't know if I got time to go into
when the city of Babylon fell back in
the days of Daniel
the children of Israel were captive in
Babylon they dried up the Euphrates
River the Persians dried up the
Euphrates River Babylon fell and the
Cyrus the the Persian General let them
go back to the promised land when it
says Euphrates is going to dry up it's
talking about Babylon falling ancient
spiritual Babylon falling God's people
go to the spiritual
Kanan Promised Land
so it is interesting that the literal
Euphrates is drying of course many
rivers in the world are drying right now
just because of droughts and War
but that there are signs when we should
flee to the cities I've got a book
called heading for the hills it's called
The Beginner's Guide to Country Living I
talk about what is the sign to flee to
the cities you may want to go to amazing
facts and pick that up just go to the
Amazing Facts website just
amazingfacts.org.com and type in the
name of the book called heading for the
hill heading for the hills and you'll be
able to learn more about how you can get
that book next caller that we have is
bestie listening in Wisconsin best we
welcome to the program
yellow
hi Bessie
thanks for taking my call I've been
working on an article that I was writing
and
um
I read
John
13 verses 34 and 35 and it's talking
about
the idea of loving one another
and the way that it says it it says it
twice and I'm wondering
it's talking if it's meaning to say to
love one another the way that
Christ
has loved us and then same
as brotherly love between
the brothers yes
yeah well of course Jesus does want us
to love one another he said by by this
all men will know you are my disciples
by your love for one another
and uh you know Paul says love is the
fulfilling of the law if we love our
neighbor we keep those Commandments
between ourselves and our fellow man
and uh yeah there's no question that
that is the great commandment John in
his first letter he says beloved let us
love one another for love is of God and
everyone who loves us born of God he
that does not love knows not God for God
is love
and so this was the central theme of the
Apostle John that is he highlighted
Jesus teaching on the quintessence of
Christianity is love and the best way
for us to show our love for God Is by
loving each other and the great judgment
Jesus is going to say
I was hungry and you fed me I was
thirsty and you gave me drink and the
Believers are going when did we do these
things for you and he says and as much
as he did it for the least of these you
did it for me so that's the big testing
criteria for if our hearts are changed
do we love each other
thank you very much Bessie and uh Pastor
Ross we've got uh one minute and 42 left
you think we can do something yeah let's
go to Bob Ray in Florida Barbara welcome
to the program we have about a minute
and a half
hello good afternoon or good evening
Pastor good evening
um I just have a question in Revelation
21 also in Philippians 3 21 it talks
about
um we having a new body like a Gloria's
body like Jesus Christ right so I'm
wondering since we won't have Flesh and
Blood anymore
um we want we will be Immortals so uh we
not going to be able to eat anymore
shower brush our teeth yeah get hungry
stuff like that well let's talk about
that it's Jesus when he rose from the
dead he ate in front of the disciples
even though he had a glorified body he
said touch me feel me a spirit does not
have flesh and bone as you see that I
have it tells us in the new Earth we
will plant Vineyards and eat the fruit
of them and we will eat from the Tree of
Life so we are definitely going to be
real in eating God is not taking away
our physical side he is adding a
spiritual Dimension so this physical is
not taken away the spiritual is added we
will still have bodies like Adam and Eve
had bodies but we'll be able to see God
and talk to angels and dwell in that
Spirit realm along with the three
dimensions we have now so yes you'll be
doing real things hey listening friends
we're gonna sign off here in a moment we
do this in two phases we say farewell to
our friends listening on satellite radio
they're on a different clock but stay
tuned the rest of you were coming back
for some Rapids fire Internet Bible
questions in just a moment
for listening to today's broadcast we
hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based Ministry located in
Granite Bay California
[Music]
Hello friends welcome back to Bible
answers live and we're going to take
some of the email questions that you
have sent in if you'd like to email us
your Bible question the email address is
just Bal questions at
amazingfacts.org so Pastor Doug question
number one were animals reproducing in
the Garden of Eden there had to be more
than two sheep or goats for God to make
clothing for the Fallen couple and it's
coming from Joseph
yeah well you know as soon as God made
Adam and Eve he told them to be fruitful
and multiply and I'm sure the other
creatures were being fruitful and
multiplying we don't know how long it
was from the time that God made Adam and
Eve until they sinned but keep in mind
sheep the gestation period is not as
long as it is for humans so it's very
likely that there were already some
flocks and they had multiplied at that
point okay next question that we have
Harrison is asking why is the Bible seem
so hard to understand
um
you know it depends on where you're
coming from for me it was very hard
because I did not grow up with a
Christian Home in Biblical context and
background I think it's easier for those
raised in Christian families that grow
up hearing the Bible and hearing the
stories and hearing preachers explain it
for me when I started reading the Bible
and I think the first one was like King
James no less I struggled but like
learning any new language there's a
certain language so to speak in the way
the Bible is written as I read it I
understood more and more now it's fairly
easy for me to you know know what the
basic context of the Bible is I'd say
keep reading and you will understand it
and it's just wonderful because even
those who study the Bible for you know
their whole lives continue to find more
and more gets deeper and deeper the
treasures are fathomless in the Bible
her next call is asking do you think God
has a sense of humor that's from Gala
you know virtually every emotion that
humans have we inherited from God
because we're Made In His Image so
people can feel anger the Bible says God
has anger uh people can feel love we
learn that from God people can have
jealousy God says I am a jealous God
people laugh the Bible actually says God
laughs
and I think that the reason that we find
certain things ironic or humorous is
because we we've learned that that's
something that we're wired from now
every emotion that God has he has those
emotions perfectly we often corrupt
those things you know we can have wrong
wrath wrong jealousy and wrong humor God
does all things well hey listening
friends it's been a delight we look
forward to studying his word with you
again next week check out
amazingfacts.org keep us on the air and
we'll study with you again next week
bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]